我父母在我很小就离婚了，然后嗯，就是因为，嗯，我爸就。
嗯，然后我嗯，我父母都是都是体制内的，然后嗯，就是家庭条件都还可以，然后也是双方都有自己的家庭和小孩啊。然后，然后我本人的性格就是嗯，控制欲强，然后有些实的极感。
然后在嗯因为也是受家庭这个影响吧，在嗯感情里面忠诚度这个上面就是可以说很偏执的。然后我就是我上一段恋情，嗯就是我我甚我甚至为了这个所谓的忠诚度，我去容忍了他理解这个事情。但是但是最后因为某些原因，就是我朋友就是开玩笑说我是嗯就是会会防产迷，就是呃虽然挺能忍的，但是好像真的到一个地步，然后自己又能清醒过来。然后然后我这一段恋情呢，就是呃我放下了很多对感情的那种执念，我的就是奔着是嗯，就是只要他适合结婚，就是我没有之前的那么恋爱了。但是呃，但是我就是但是一旦陷入一段感情，我就还是会有一点就是一半清醒一半沉迷的那种感觉啊，我现在这个男朋友就是。
嗯，他是一个边界感特别差的人。
当然，我也不否认我自己是控制欲比较强的，而且，嗯，但是这个我也有做心理准备。然后，在我跟他交往这几年期间，我多次强调了我就是我需要的是一个什么样的对象，就是如果你不满足我的需求，对吧，我们就就可以好聚好散，这个没关系的。然后呢，他对我表示的也是特别真诚，特特别那样，但是，但是在谈恋爱这几年间，就总是有一些真界感的事情。你能给我举个例子吗？就是有感，嗯，就是呃，比如说，呃。
呃，上班期间经常和女同事打游戏啊，那种女同事打游戏有单独和女同事去吃饭吗？看电影吗？单独和女同事去嗯做一些户外的一些活动吗？真的没有。然后就是嗯，他会喜欢和嗯，他就是这么多年来的一些嗯，他所谓的普通异性朋友，还有网上的一些女网友去聊天，他的所有的你认为边界感不好的都是停留在网上是吧，啊不是也也有实际的。
就是啊，也我我我这里你说清楚，就是没有说那种很越轨，比如说单独跟别人有很亲密的行为，或者是怎么样，也许是我这个人吧。但是在我眼里，我觉得和异性朋友的就是那个相处的嗯边界吧，就是就是就比如说他会和异性在网络上聊天，他的那种氛围很暧，对对，就是那个分寸感。比如说像这种小宝贝，嗯，就是就是比如说他和我吵架之后，他永远就是会和他那些女性朋友去谈论我。然后还有就是比如说我说他同事就不仅是打游戏这个事情，他可能跟一个呃刚来的一个呃女女同事，然后就呃就很热情的去给别人带早餐，就是类似于那种就激情。我现在因为我也没办法说很多这些事情，你是怎么知道的呢？嗯，就是从手机里面发现的呗，就是说你会经常去看他的手机，比如说他的外卖订单，比如说他的嗯没有。其实我是很喜欢看，但是我也知道一些道理，别人不是说了嘛，就是呃，除非你是真不想跟他过，或者说你要结婚了，你才会去选择看他的手机，对吧。
不然不然你你你看了，但是你又选择去原谅他，这其实是一种很不好的方式，就是很多都是无意中看到的，并不是说我刻意的去翻查他的手机，因为我觉得这样也很内耗我自己。嗯，你现在的工作是做什么呀？哦，在一个国企哦，那男方呢，是做什么工作呢？嗯嗯，研究方面的吧，你和他之间的感情就是客观的评价，是你爱他更多，还是他爱你更多？说实话，我一直觉得他爱我更多。但是我，我我真的会因为就是这些边界感的事情而质疑我对他的话。就我我不否认我对他有感情，但是如果说相比上一任，肯定是没有那么久。那结婚这个事儿，是你推进的，还是他推进的？他推进的吧，他推荐多一点吧，因为反正我。
我是奔着结婚去的，然后他也比较那个这个事情啊，龙飞姐呢没有办法帮你来做这个决定，要不要跟他结婚这个事儿，决定还是在你手上。但是龙是不是最近出现了一个事情，我刚刚没有讲清楚，就是我刚刚讲的那些是前提。然后最近是因为我们准备领券了，然后最后一次我是真正的查了他的手机，然后我发现。
啊就是之前有那些就是我会让他把那些乱七八糟的女生删掉，然后呢，我我我这一次发现他应该是什么时候嗯加了回来。然后其中又有就是被次我的内容就是聊天这种。然后现在就是因为因为我马上就要，然后就可以就双方就家庭就就要遭受的巨大的损失，以及就是丢脸嘛。所以我现在就是很被动，我现在就是所有的压力都给到我，意思就是就包括我自己家人是什么，哎呀，你你你以后找一个呃，他也不可能保证就怎么怎么样啊，你要考虑清楚啊。他其他方面还是很不错啊，就是这种，但是我我内心来说，我是接受不了这种坎的，我可以就是我知道没有男人会绝对这样或者说，但是我为什么要找他呢，我完全可以找另一个，就是啊，同样花心。但是其他方面可不可以给我就是更好的一点情绪，或者什么样的呢？王菲姐，嗯，我真诚的跟你真诚的跟你讲，我感受到你的状态，你的状态需要调整。不管你跟这个男人，还是跟另外一个男人，还是说怎么样的话，就这个婚，你不管结不结的话，你现在自己的状态是需要调整的，为什么需要调整呢？是因为。
因为你目标不明确，你没有一个清晰的说我想要什么的明确的目标。如果说我想要的是一个对我绝对忠诚的人的话，那你就要找那个你的条件可能比他要好一些。他能找到你祖坟上冒青烟了，他能找到你当老婆，他横看也漂亮，竖看也欢心。他觉得跟你在一起老有面子了，跟你在一起带出去的话，都是对吧，恨不得把初中同学、高中同学、大学同学全招过来，要看看我现在找的女朋友多优秀。你明白我慧姐讲的逻辑吗？如果你就是爱看这个表面给骗了。嗯，如果你想要找一个对你特忠诚的人的话，你得奔着这个方向去找。如果你一方面想要找一个对你忠诚的人，另一方面，又希望这个人还能够在其他物质条件啊，在各方面还能给你提供一点什么。他他还特别优秀，特别有女人缘的话，我告诉你，这就是自己走进死胡同了。没有这样的，就一定要特别明确的知道自己想要的是什么，或者说回过头来看一看这些你现在所谓的想要的，真的是你需要的吗？
你需要的是什么？可能就是因为爸妈离婚了，爸妈都找了人了。你需要的是被看见被关注，对吧？被被别人当成一个对吧？忠心被别人当成一个宝贝。你需要的是这个。嗯，在你还没有在一个男人身上感受到这个东西的时候，不要轻易领结婚证，他的都可以同居啊，什么的可以啊，订婚了什么的没问题啊，但不要轻易领结婚证，这个我所以所以就是在结婚之前，就是领证之前发生这件事情。所以我现在就是强烈的不同意领这个结婚证。但是就是家里也是觉得我肯定会原谅他，然后就是还是要自结婚这个事情，这个事情要尊重自己的内心啊。如果你就假设嘛，就龙梅姐说，假设你要跟这个男的继续过下去的话，你必须要跟这个男的有一次敞开心扉的真诚的一次啊。这一次沟通在这个沟通的过程当中，不要带着指责，不要带着那种不满愤懑，要带着什么一种状态呢？就是剖析自己，把自己抛开了给他看。我就是因为缺乏安全感，我就是因为想要被你看见，被你重视，被你当成唯一，我才会觉得幸福。
啊，甚至可以举几个例子，就是刚开始你跟我在一起的时候，你做了什么事情？比如说，你跟你的异性朋友和我我们一起吃饭的时候，你给我夹菜，我就会觉得很幸福啊。比如说，刚开始我们俩在一起的时候，在送谁回家的时候，你呃义无反顾的选择要送我回家，然后，没有跟其他的那些女孩有什么暧昧的这个举动，我也会觉得很幸福。这就叫一种正向的引导，把自己抛开了给他看我需要的是什么。这些东西你做到了，那我们的关系的基石就有了。可能平时你钓个鱼啊，对吧，你出去玩啊，你打个游戏啊，我可能就不在意了。我可能就不管你了。你就如果你要跟这个人在一起的话，就需要一次彻底的敞开心扉的这样一次沟通。
OK, 反正就是领证这个事儿一定是你心里面确信这个，对吧？最起码当下咱不管以后啊，最起码当下你确信这个，你你的心理需求在这个男生身上是得到了反馈和满足的。你再去领那个结婚证，与此同时的话，也要调整自己的内心需求。调整自己的内心需求是什么意思呢？就是说认识到自己控制欲强，认识到自己有点偏执，同时也要去抽离出来。我怎么做才能让自己控制欲没有那么强？对，当你把注意力放在喜欢自己爱自己这件事情上的时候，你对别人的控制就会下降。我我确实也是嗯，看了你一一两年的视频还有直播之后，觉得自己也改变了很多。我知道自己身上也是有挺大问题的，挺好挺好意识到看到。
嗯，离做到就差就差这么一步了，就认识到了本身就很好。下一步就是我做到谢谢，嗯，拜拜。其实，龙飞姐能够理解，嗯，什么样的状态下控制欲比较强。其实说穿了，就是自己还不是特别自信的时候，控制欲就比较强。就是自己拥有的东西很少，所以特别想把仅有的这些东西都牢牢的拽在手里，就会控制欲强。如果我们自己拥有的东西多了，就是我不光拥有男女情爱，我还拥有自己的事业，拥有自己的兴趣爱好，拥有自己的朋友，拥有自己的一些嗯精神乐园吧，就是自己的一些精神追求。这个时候，你手上拥有的东西多了之后，你反而就不会对某一样东西产生那么强的控制欲，那么害怕失去一样东西。换句话说，当一个女人特别有魅力，恨不得喜欢你的男的啊，能从你们单位排到你们家门口啊，喜欢你的男的从初中高中大学恨不得排到法国。其实那种控制欲就会减弱，因为你不再害怕失去某一个人，不再害怕失去某一个人对你的关注，对你的宠爱，反而。
这个关系是比较好相处的，但凡是自己拥有的东西很少攥在手里，仅仅就是情爱这么一点东西的时候，其实对方也很痛苦。我这边有男同学吧，男同学可以给龙飞姐说一下，就是你有没有谈过这样的女朋友？就是你觉得跟他谈恋爱你喜欢她吗？你喜欢她，但你就觉得跟他谈恋爱真的很累，真的很累，没有有的答有。那你为什么会觉得累？就是因为对方他拥有的东西特别少。你是他仅仅拥有的这么一点点东西，他就会死死的拽住你，你就会觉得很累很窒息。